I still look back and cringe like why
did I do that
yikes I met a girl while I was on
vacation and we just had this amazing
time together and I liked her a lot
we had negating for six months I just
felt like it was a very time to say I
love you but they need the hopeless
romantic that it was I want to make some
grand like huge gesture to say I love
you who I'd been seeing this girl for a
month but I was already thinking and
like my logical brain was like nope too
soon too soon
don't even think of it don't even say it
we were doing doing this make in the sex
a hen's I remember coming up for air if
you will I looked up to her she looked
down at me and said I love you I didn't
know what to say
so I said oh you're cute yeah I decided
I was gonna surprise her with a picnic
at the beach and fly some kites what she
didn't know was that on these kites I
had written I love you in big bold
letters and in my mind she was gonna fly
it see it and fall out with me blah we
go front like in the water for a bit I'm
twirling her in the air and I just said
I love you and she immediately screamed
she was like and then she proceeded to
dunk my head into the water and try to
drown me I thought I was going to die
cuz it felt like eternity but when she
pinked when she let go of my head she
just said thank you we just get back to
my apartment after and having a night
out we're drinking wine and we start
watching Beyonce music videos we get to
the song drunk in love and after it
finishes I just I turn to her and I say
I love you like an idiot her face kind
of dropped and she's just like what it
was like the worst moment ever to not be
ready to say you love a person back and
I should just did it but I felt like
more of an upstanding person by just
like no I'm gonna be real with me
and just say that you're cute we stayed
together and it was very quickly after
where I had
admit that to say I love you because it
was an argument this is pretty awkward
walk back to the shore I was really sad
but in my head I was like I wrote I love
you on these kites and I was like let's
just fly this just I did all this work
might as well we were flying the kites
and then after a minute she looked up
and saw that I wrote I love you in bold
letters and she just dropped the kites
and then came up to me and said I love
you back
we dated for four more years after that
so I think it worked out moral the story
is if your partner tries to drown you
after you say I love you there's still a
glimmer of hope don't give up few days
later she like comes to my apartment
with like a dozen roses and she says I'm
sorry with that I'm sorry about how I
reacted the other night and I was like
oh cool and then a month after that she
said I love you to me we've been
together ever since we're still together
Beyonce brought us together honestly
like let's that's our song that's gonna
be playing at our wedding like we're not
engaged yet I've just here I'm jumping
the gun with that